and now it's time for bumming reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review where the wild things
are seen in my life no no who's there
spoilers Julius this movie is based on
this children's book one of the greatest
children busts I've ever seen in my life
it's about a kid who goes to an island
he finds a bunch of monsters they have a
good time and then he goes back home
there was incredible
why can't poor children's books be that
way it was simple not complicated like
that other book grenades in half oh wait
that was made dinner so in the movie
there's this boy and he declares himself
king of the monsters and I'm like no
you're not you don't look anything like
Godzilla sushi gets in an argument with
his mother if I argument you mean
fighting or not I bet someone's neck
once you know the president is not a
good sport told her mother tries to
punish him and send him to its room so
the kid is the only sensible thing he
can think of get lines in about it sails
away to an island full of monster and so
he comes across all the monsters there
and one of them is voiced by Tony
Soprano
and he's like girl yo I'm a monster you
can to prep her with it if you do I
freaking eat you he's a monster monster
so the monsters declares you kids are
king of the monsters in there like
what's our first order of business King
and the kid is like oh stop free so they
run around doing stuff but then a kid is
like let's do better stop ready so they
built a giant Death Star made out of
toothpicks and one of the monsters is
like I want you to meet Bob and Terry
and it turns out Bob and Terry are these
two owls from Harry Potter
except for the soprano monster he's like
now I don't like these two pigeons I
think they should be whacked but by
being carried to fit their case Nick
interview with in so the monsters start
to suspect that the kid is not really a
teen selection is like we had fun doing
stuff free but the stuff is so the kid
goes away on his little rap and the
mustard start Halloween to the sky call
decreased table of death severe and it
loves you so legit returns home with his
mother is waiting and at first she gives
in the creepy hug another like you might
be wondering what's the moral of the
story kids the moral of the story is
damn in it just stay overnight your
family's not permit dear annex you
trapped in an island with monsters stay
with it using the pine cone where people
occasionally urinate on you and throw
feces at you always saying that they let
their change at home even though I see
the paper a hooker just on the side of
the street forgive this cruel horrible
world died alone in the darkness bite
your finger enjoy simply crying oh and
also eat your vegetables
this is history boom scene change come
on where the wild things where they are
just don't have any cups of them